today we're going to use flutter to
build a clock and not just any ordinary
clock but a binary clock just a few days
ago the flutter team launched a new
competition where the goal is to build
the most beautiful clock face I don't
plan on entering this competition myself
so this video is more of a QuickStart
guide to get you started building your
own clock from scratch as you'll see in
a few minutes
building a clock and flutter is really
easy so in order to make this video a
little more challenging I also want to
teach you everything you didn't know
about binary and if you're entering the
flutter clock competition make sure to
watch until the end of the video because
I'll be sharing additional clock ideas
there that you're more than welcome to
steal from me if you're new here like
and subscribe and you can grab the full
source code from fire ship IO in order
to build a binary clock we need to know
a little bit about how binary works in
mathematics a binary number is just a
number that has two possible States
which we can represent as a 0 or 1 you
can think of this logically as true or
false or electronically as on off and in
computer systems we call a single binary
value a bit now a single bit by itself
can't represent very much just two
values to be precise so how do we make
bits represent more complex data well we
simply combine them together when you
combine bits together it creates a
geometric series where the number of
different values we can represent is
determined by 2 to the power of the
number of bits that we have so 2 to the
power of 1 equals 2 which means we can
represent two things 2 to the power of 2
is 4 so we can represent 4 things with 2
bits but when talking about bits we
usually think about them grouped in
series of 8 which is a single bite a
bite would be 2 to the power of 8 which
can represent 256 different things now
the reason we call 8 bits a byte is
somewhat arbitrary it's just a good even
number and contains a enough space for
all the letters of the alphabet and
uppercase and lowercase for example you
may have heard of utf-8 which stands for
8 bit Unicode transformation format it
encodes millions of different characters
from languages around the world
including emojis and does so by
combining 1 2 4 8 bit bytes together so
whenever you use Unicode characters in
your code which is all the time each
character is actually encoded to a
binary value and the computer uses that
value to look in this giant table to
figure out which character to actually
show on the screen or the UI in fact
here's a cool little trick you can do in
your dart code start with a string and
then
rabbits actual character code from the
utf-8 table by calling code unit at a
given index in that string that will
give you a base ten decimal by default
if you want to convert it to binary call
to radix string with a base of two radix
is just another name for bass so it's
taking the original base ten number that
we normally use and converting it to a
base two binary value so that's how
binary works to high-level but how do we
actually use the ones and zeros to
represent more complex data like how do
we use binary to tell time you can see
we have six columns on the clock where
each column is used to represent a digit
in time blue shows the hours green the
minutes and pink the seconds the large
colorful numbers represent the time in
digits that you would be familiar with
and you'll see our flutter clock is
synced up with the actual device clock
now each one of the cells or the
intersection between a row and a column
represents a bit
notice how inside of every cell we have
a number this is the actual value that
that bit represents so the bottom row
represents one's the second row
represents twos third row fours and the
top row aids if none of the cells are
highlighted then it represents a zero if
there's just a single cell highlighted
then you can assume that it represents
that number but if you have multiple
cells highlighted then you get the value
by adding them together for example if
we look at the first column we don't
have any bits highlighted so that means
it's a zero if we go to the next column
we have an eight and a one highlighted
add those together and you get nine
continue that process for all the other
columns and that's how you read a binary
clock you'll notice that some of the
columns have four rows but others only
have two or three you'll notice the
column with four rows represents the
ones position four hours minutes and
seconds we need four bits for these
columns because their value can range
from 0 to 9 and 4 bits allows us to
represent 16 different values but when
it comes to seconds in minutes we only
need to represent 6 values because a
clock can only go up to 60 seconds or 60
minutes and we can represent 6 values
with 3 bits and when it comes to hours
there's only 24 hours in a day which
means we only need to represent a 0 1 or
a 2 which we can do with 2 bits so now
that you know how a binary clock works
let's go ahead and build one from
scratch with flutter let's go ahead and
get started from a new flutter project
if you're entering the competition you
can clone the repo from the con
homepage we do have one dependency for
our app int L so we'll go ahead and add
that to the pub spec yeah mol it's used
for date formatting and localization of
timestamps which tends to be pretty
useful if you're building a clock inside
the main dot dart file we'll go ahead
and import dart async dart math and then
we'll use system chrome and device
orientation from the flutter services
package the competition requires that
the app is in landscape mode so in our
main function we'll go ahead and use
system Chrome to set the preferred
orientations to landscape left or
landscape right and moving down to the
app itself we have a material app with
some basic theme data and then we have a
scaffold whose body is the clock
stateful widget so the entire app will
basically be coated inside of this
stateful widget that we're giving a name
of o'clock the first thing we'll want to
do is make our clock tick every second
we'll set up a property name now which
is equal to date/time now this is
actually the only state that we have on
the widget and the state will change
every second for every tick of the clock
we can set that up during the Annette
State lifecycle hook where we set up a
periodic timer with a duration of one
second that gives us a callback function
where we'll call set state to update the
now value now because we're building a
binary clock I'm going to abstract some
of the logic into my own custom class
called binary time this will take the
logic of converting a timestamp to
binary outside of the widget which will
make it a little easier to maintain and
hopefully easier to read but we actually
want here for our UI is an array of
strings where each string represents the
ones and zeros needed to display a given
column in the clock we'll call that list
binary integers and when this class is
instantiated
we'll grab the timestamp and then we'll
convert that timestamp to the hour
minute second format now by default the
hours minutes and seconds will be
separated by a colon which we don't need
and we can get rid of the colons by
using replace all with an empty string
that will give us a string with a length
of 6 and then we'll map each element
first to an integer then to a radix
string with a radix or base of two if
you remember earlier we talked about how
binary values have a base of two radix
is just another name for the base so
what it's doing is taking this integer
and converting it to a string of ones
and zeros I'd recommend playing around
with this a little bit on
artpad for example you can take an
integer and convert it to a radix string
with a given base or you can convert a
string back to an integer by passing in
a radix argument of two so unless you're
some kind of psychopath who understands
how to convert base-10 to base-2 I'd
recommend playing around with this a
little bit the last thing I'm going to
do is pad each of the binary integers
with zeros on the left side if they
don't exist this just makes them easier
to loop over when we get to the UI and
also to make our UI code a little more
readable I'm going to set up a getter
for each of the positions in the clock
the clock represents time in a base 10
system so we have the hours 10 position
the hours 1 position
the minutes tens and so on so that's how
we convert all of the base 10 digits in
a clock to binary now we just need to
loop over them and show a column in the
UI for each of the binary values so in
our state for widget will setup a
container with a little bit of padding
then we'll set up a row and this row
will contain six clock columns the clock
column will be a custom stateless widget
that we'll build next instead of
creating a loop here I'm just adding
each of the clock columns manually so we
can adjust the title the color and the
number of rows that are actually
displayed and each column takes a
different binary integer based on the
value of the clock that it's meant to
represent now each column will display
four rows so we'll go ahead and
implement that logic in this stateless
clock column widget it will take a few
input properties so we can customize the
title color and things like that as well
as the binary integer that it represents
and one additional property called bits
which will just be an array of the
values in the binary integer which will
contain four values of ones and zeros
inside the build method we'll go ahead
and set up a column we'll set the main
axis alignment to space between and then
the first child of that column will be
the title now the interesting part here
is showing the active cells inside the
column will do that by looping over the
four bits in the column but one kind of
annoying thing about dart is that it
does not allow us to access the index
inside of a map operation we can
overcome this limitation by simply
converting the list to a map grabbing
its entries then we can set local
variables for the value and the index
the settle is considered active if the
bit equals one if it's zero then it's
inactive you'll also notice in the UI
that each end
we'll sell shows the base-10 value that
that bit represents so how do we convert
a bit to a base 10 integer well if you
remember from earlier it's simply a
power of two so we'll take the power of
two and then raise it to three minus the
index we do 3 minus the index and not
the index directly because we're
actually looping and reverse here we're
starting with the highest value and then
going down to the lowest value so that
should be all the computation we need
for the UI so at this point we'll go
ahead and return an animated container
and then we'll set the duration to
around 500 milliseconds just so we can
animate the color when it goes from
active to inactive if we look at the box
decoration for the container you can see
if it's active we show the color that we
passed as an input property otherwise if
the index is less than 4 minus the Rose
then we'll go ahead and make that
invisible by setting the opacity to zero
otherwise we'll go ahead and show a
black or inactive cell then as the child
of the animated container we'll go ahead
and show the actual binary value in base
10 and we'll give it some opacity just
so it blends in with the existing cell
color then down below the cells I'll go
ahead and use integer parse with a radix
value of two this will convert the
binary integer to a decimal in base 10
format and then down below that we'll go
ahead and show the binary integer itself
in a smaller font size and that's all
there is to it we now have a fully
functional binary clock built with
flutter my hope with this video is that
someone watches it builds their own
clock and flutter and wins the
competition and there's some pretty
decent prizes for the top entries a
thing to keep in mind is that the point
of this competition is to build the UI
for the Lenovo smart display so a binary
clock might not be exactly what they're
going for but here are a few other ideas
that you might use to hopefully win this
competition one potential idea is to
integrate text into your clock so
instead of showing the digits at 7:30
you would say it is half-past seven so
you just need to write a little dart
algorithm that converts to a time stamp
into a human readable sentence another
idea is to recreate the classic flip
clock this should be relatively easy to
execute with flutter animation and your
own custom graphics also consider
building a clock that adjusts its color
gradient based on the time so the color
gradient will adjust every second
becoming darker at night and brighter
today ultimately I think the winning
design will be something that is clean
and modern that incorporates some
animation I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and consider
becoming a pro member at bioship i/o to
get access to the full flutter chorus
and a bunch of other exclusive content
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]